[Music]
prince louis steals the show again and
this time it involves teasing his mom
kate middleton
it all went down at the queen's platinum
jubilee pageant which concluded the
celebratory weekend louis sat next to
his family his siblings princess
charlotte and prince george his parents
prince william and kate middleton and
grandparents prince charles and camilla
things were going well until louis stood
on his seat then at one point he covered
his mom's mouth as she was speaking to
him but the most memorable moment when
louie held a hand up to his nose and
stuck his tongue out at kate
[Music]
kids will be kids even at a platinum
jubilee right but there were a few sweet
moments as well like this one of louis
hugging his mom and this shot bouncing
on his grandfather prince charles's lap
[Music]
louie's latest antics come just days
after he stole the spotlight at the
trooping the color ceremony
as the four-year-old stood next to his
great-grandmother he made some silly
faces that the crowd couldn't get enough
of the four-year-old had the best facial
expressions as he wildly waved to the
crowd and chatted to his
great-grandmother the queen
oh and louie wasn't here for the loud
aircrafts
his antics had his sister charlotte
actually scolding him at one point
telling him to pay attention
of course the platinum jubilee has been
a big family weekend for the cambridges
as the queen celebrates 70 years on the
throne ahead of the pageant kensington
palace shared this sweet slideshow of
the kiddos baking cupcakes with their
mom for the jubilee street party in
cardiff and although her royal highness
missed a majority of events she did make
a surprise appearance on the balcony of
buckingham palace with the family to cap
off the four-day celebration
she also shared a special thank you note
for everyone who helped her mark the
occasion writing in a statement quote
while i may not have attended every
event in person my heart has been with
you all and i remain committed to
serving you to the best of my ability
supported by my family
[Music]